hey y'all welcome to this week's episode
of is this okay where we talk about
things that are happening in the world
wondering if it's okay I'm nya
I'm deja I'm Chris I'm Nick I'm Claudia
hey welcome guys
this week our topic of discussion is
whitewashing in Hollywood the other
night I saw Kubo in the two strings and
so it's this beautiful film about a
Japanese family and whatever reason I
just had this itch where I was like I
got to check and see who the voices are
out of the five main characters or stick
I was the only yeah I was an only one
who was Asian you'll kind of wonder why
there's none of the eight people in the
movie were actually Japanese this has
been happening for a very long time
guess we've seen it with Emma Stone so
remember you Tilda Swinton as the
ancient one and Scarlett Johansson as
ghost in the shell' there's also this
argument that you know well these white
actors are just more talented and I
think that that's the argument that
really urges me so insulting let's say
that they've gotten more training or
more schooling so that thus makes them
more talented why haven't we as a
society said that like oh well there's
this whole other group of people that
aren't getting the training that they
need to be able to compete on the same
level let's figure out how to fix that
this is all the funny actors we know and
they just all happen to be white and
male and it's like what you're pulling
from a comedy school that needs like a
certain level of socioeconomic status to
be able to succeed in and also from
cultures that don't encourage going into
that industry right and then when you
are very set on a certain type of comedy
- you're not gonna get the Leslie
Jones's like you're not used to a type
of comedy what stars can be made stars
can be built and Studios have to commit
to finding those people I also just
think about it in terms of like being a
black woman and how I could never depict
a story but like as a white person like
that's just not my story to tell we
talked about fresh off the boat and all
these shows are about the struggle of
this specific type of ethnicity I really
want to have a black family that's not
about being black also a show where the
emotions are universal not specific to a
niche I think I get what you're saying
but I also think like when you are a
person of color your color comes with
you no matter what when you are white
you have the option
to either address it or to not address
it you see that seems like the ultimate
right yeah is to have the option you can
still it you if you make a movie about
slavery you've got to talk about racism
if you make a movie like a science
fiction movie with Will Smith and his
son awesome example you don't have to
talk about it because that's not what
they're dealing with they're know and
see so I think context is key so it's
like if you have a sci-fi movie and it's
just you have happen to have a black
lead that's totally fine like you don't
necessarily have to delve into that but
it's like if you have a show dealing
with a black family life like you know
that kind of thing I think that it would
be would be watering it down yeah like
it just wouldn't be true to the
experience of like my everyday life if
you're like deep diving into like
someone's or a groups experience in
terms of like a movie or TV show I think
it would look a little bit more strange
to like not talk about those issues or
those struggles but like I also think
that what you're trying to say there are
plenty of spaces and we need more spaces
we're like we're just allowed to be
happy
it just exists ideally you get
representation for both you get
something that is just centered around a
certain struggle and like why there
needs to be a spotlight on a certain
thing and you get the film that's just
like a beautiful rom-com where like the
lead is a black man or the lead is like
a Latina woman and then I guess that's
hitch pretty much
I do think that Hollywood definitely
exploits that so we have the struggle
film where it's just kind of like oh
like Tyrone who grew up in the hood but
he sold drugs to get out and like haha
and I think that that's just a storyline
at Hollywood's like oh it's sold once
like during the blaxploitation era so
we'll just keep repeating it over and
over and over again and I think it goes
back to that point that was brought up
last week is that like money is kind of
power so it's like we have to be
thinking about like when we do watch
those films and whatnot like what are we
telling Hollywood executives that we're
willing to invest in what's interesting
also that most movies make their other
than comedies most movies make their
real revenue internationally and ones
that have international looking stars do
better that's why the rock is the
biggest star right now unfortunately I
think there's so much truth in that but
then it takes people in power like
literally just making good moral
decisions that like help other people
and it's like how do you tell it to
somebody when all they see is dollar
signs Nick I have a question for you as
an actor if a studio tomorrow was like
hey we have this really big blockbuster
film with Suniya war if we love it but
we want you to play X brace and I just
to be fair before you answer I can offer
any support like I have struggled with
that idea - in the sense of like if out
of nowhere I was offered like a role in
a Woody Allen film like and that was my
big break and I have all these thoughts
of like I don't know what that is about
and I do judge actors that take roles in
that it hasit don't know their
circumstance like it's a really tricky
question it's a weird thing as an actor
you get used to not turning down roles
especially if you're an aspiring actor
so if I or anybody else that I know is
offered a role that they think they can
do something with then yeah I think they
should take it
I don't like shaming actors that
apologize afterwards but I think part of
it is like the authenticity of the
Impala G and feeling like you know this
person is actually learning from their
mistakes I see a lot of people that [ __ ]
up make apologies that like I really
hope that this sparks more conversation
about the issue and I'm and I'm like
we've been talking about this like don't
like there are no cookies for you for
like making everybody pissed about
apologies I'm like with that fly with
like your husband or wife all of this is
why I am participating so heavily in new
media because I think like this new
media has become like a very blooming
space for people of color to tell their
stories because there's all in their own
terms so I think we've come down to a
conclusion that whitewashing is the real
thing and it's just not not cool okay
yeah okay okay so leave your comments
below and we will see you next week
[Music]